I got some you've probably seen or at
least heard about the summer blockbuster
Straight Outta Compton by now
the movie dramatizes the emergence of
Southern California rap group NWA what
you may not know is that NWA got caught
in a First Amendment fight with the
government over their music and what's
worse is that rappers today are still
fighting for their free expression in
1988 the group's album Straight Outta
Compton popularized gangster rap music
with graphic lyrics one of the most
graphic was [ __ ] the police the song
seems scary with lyrics like beautiful
eSATA shape and taken out police will
make my day
but according to NWA the song's lyrics
were just to get your attention the real
message was a criticism of police
harassment and intimidation of black
people in South Central Los Angeles what
they look like but federal law
enforcement took the lyrics literally
1989 NWA's record label received a
warning letter from the feds saying the
lyrics to [ __ ] the police encouraged
violence against and disrespect for the
law enforcement officer NWA only gained
more street cred after they went public
with the letter and eventually Straight
Outta Compton was selected as one of
Rolling Stones 500 best albums of all
time
but as aspiring gangster rappers across
the United States had tried to mimic the
success of NWA they end up having their
larger-than-life rap lyrics used against
them in criminal proceedings there's no
way in the world these people were gonna
be able to charge me with shootings
based on what I rap about in my music
San Diego rapper Brandon Duncan spent 8
months in jail accused of conspiring to
commit a series of gang-related
shootings
Duncan was an accused of planning being
at the shootings or pulling the trigger
prosecutors claimed Duncan willfully
promoted and benefited from the
shootings through his gangsta rap album
no safety
to the [ __ ] that beat rusher well
we're not that's the local da in court
and he also points out to the judge that
the cover of Duncan's album has a gun
with bullets on it but Duncan says all
of this is posturing it's like playing a
character in a violent movie the more
shooting you have in a movie the more it
you know I mean people working pillow
tonight you know I mean to really really
really want to tune in say Al Pacino
movie Scarface he was Tony Montana well
he goes home he's Al Pacino you know the
name so when he goes home I don't think
he's snorting cocaine and shooting
people is just that's who he played on
that movie
that may be the most interesting part of
all of this rappers today reflect the
realities and song lyrics just like NWA
did and at least four musicians like
Duncan he also dreams of making a life
that's better for himself in his
community
rap is my way out that's the whole thing
about rap is you know me you create this
platform to where you can help a whole
lot of people you know that normally
wouldn't have helped that normally will
be stuck right there and that ghetto you
know I'm gonna be stuck in that saying
in that hood